this small band of men have been holding  this position for weeks now  coming under constant attack every few  hours from russian positions  oh here we go end law they proudly show  us some of the foreign weapons which  have helped so far where's this one from  it's from britain  they're designed to destroy tanks at  short range with a single shot and they  need little training to operate  but here in the forest and farmland its  capability is limited ivan tells us  in this position it isn't that effective  he says because their tanks don't come  closer than three and a half kilometers  and this weapon can't reach the target  at that distance effectively  they need long range artillery and tanks  themselves he says if they're to stop  this reinvigorated russian invasion